Các đầy tảm người nằm giới sự lánh đạo của đàn độ sản Việt Nam và chủ tịch hồ chí mình,
nhân dân ta đã làm nên một thu lịch sự.
Đó là tháng lợi cuộc cách mặt tháng tảm đất tàn ec áp bức,
móc lột nặng nè của chế độ thực dân và phong kiến,
sàng lấy chính quyền lập nên nực Việt Nam sân chủ cộng qua.
Đây là cuộc cách mặt khi đại, là mốc sòn trói loại trong lịch sự giữ nước và giữ nước phẹ phang của giân tập ta.
Viet nằm từ một sứ thuộc hiện nửa phong kiến, đã trở thành nước tự gió nóc lập.
Nhân dân thử thân phận nô lệ trở thành người làm chủ đất nước, làm chủ phận mạnh của mình.
Những mốc sòn của cuộc tộc khởi nghĩa tháng tảm nằm một yên chính trọng bố mê làm.
Hắn chính nó một yên chính trảm bà chính, chính tránh thây giới thực 2 bùng nộ,
thực dân pháp đến hành khủng bố tảm khóc, của tiêu các quyền tự gió sân chủ tối tiểu
mà nhân dân ta đã sành giật trong thời gian mặt trạng dân chủ.
Nó một yên chính trọng bố mời nhật vào đông dương,
nhân dân ta chức cạnh thân một câu 2 trọng nô lệ.
Các hội dị trụ ơn lên thứ 6, hắn mùi một nằm một yên chính trọng bố mời,
chủ trân đe cao dựng bụng sải hắn dân ta.
Dự lúc cao trọng hát mặt phát triển mạnh mẽ,
ngày hai tháng hắn bộ nằm một yên chính trọng bố mời mốt,
sau nhiều năm hạt động ở lớn ngoài, đông chỉ hồ chính mình trở về nước,
chực tiếp lãnh đạo phòng trọng hát mặt.
Hội dị trụ ơn lên thứ 8, họp tại Pháp Bỏ, hạ quảng cao bằng,
tương ngày mùm gười đến ngày người chính tháng 6, 1.5,
sau lãnh tụ hồ chính mình trụ chỉ, đã hoàn trình đường lỗi chỉ đạo chỉ lợ.
Để cao hơn nước vẫn đề sân tọng, chủ trường thành lập mặt trạng về nước,
hoàn đếp hết thải mọi người Việt Nam yêu nước, tất cả trình bị mọi dụ kẹt cho khởi nghĩa vũ trang
sải chính quyền.
Này 1 chỉ tháng 8, 1.5, 1 đạo chỉ Pháp, đảng phát đợp phòng trọng hắn nhật từ nước trên phản quốc.
Ngày 1.5, 1.5, 1.5, 1 đạo chỉ thì, nhật Pháp phán nhau và hành động của chúng ta,
khẳng định đây là thời cơ tốt để nhìn dần tạo phòng lên sành động lập.
Hợi giết thân phần nổ ra ở nhiều điều phương, tắt chính khu, các cứ điện được đầy máy xây dự.
Này 1.5, 1.5, 1.5, 1 đất khi nhật người công hảm cho các nước đồng mình,
nế nghĩ mở cục đàn phán nguồn bán.
Chứ hợi cơ đó, nè người bà thử tảm nằm của mình chỉ chăm 4 năm,
đặt ta chợi tập pho í tru hơn trên cơ sở ở giá tình hình thế giới và trong nước,
đá khẳng định cơ hội tổ hình như sạy chỉ quyền tắt ở ý.
Này trong đêm, quý bà khởi giết và nguồn xa quân lạng số một hạ lạc tổ hình như.
Nè người sấu thẳng tảm nằm của mình chỉ chăm 4 năm,
đại hội quốc dân học đại tân trào, thúc hòa lạc tổ hình như,
quý định quốc y là là tự đỏ sau phản năm cạnh,
quốc cà là bài tiếng quân cà,
thành lập ui bán dân dân dài khoảng Việt Nam sau đồng chiếm một chiếm mình làm chú tình.
Chú tình hồ chiếm mình gọi thứ kêu gọi nên dân cà nước, tổ hình hãi giữa.
Giờ quyết định cho vận mạnh dân tổ tả đã đến,
khoản quốc đồng bà hạnh đứng dài đêm xích tả mất tự dài khoảng cho tả.
Gần hai chăm chiến sĩ dài khoảng xích quan tự cây đào tân trào,
linh đường, tính xang thái miền, tính vệ hà nội.
Với sự lãnh đạo của đàn,
2.5 trộ đồng bà ca,
với tình thần đêm xích tả mặt dài khoảng cho tả,
đã nhất tệ phục lên dành chính quyền trong nguyên lâm này,
từ ngày 18 đến ngày 8, 30 năm, 1 yên chính trăm 4.5.
Chấm giết sự thống chiếc gần chăm 5 của thực dân,
và hàng ít năm của không kiến,
hết lập nền dân trù cậu hoài.
Thắng lợi tổ cách mặt thân tảm,
và việc thân lập nhả nước,
việc nằm dân trù cậu hoài,
là thắng lợi của không đường chú nước,
giòn miệng ai khói,
và sự mạnh của quan rất tập,
giữ sự lãnh đạo của đàn cậu sản Việt Nam.
Tả mấy năm đã trôi qua,
tầm vóc ím,
nếu bài học kinh nghiệp với báo của các bạn thẳng tảm 5.5.
Vẫn còn nguyên giả trị,
và tức tục qua sáng trong sự nghiệp cách mặt của đất nước.
Các bạn thẳng tảm,
đã trở thành giấu móc lịch sự phố cùng quan trọng,
mở ra một thời đại phát triển dựng dưỡc dưỡc của đất nước,
với những chiến công oanh nghiệp,
như chiến thẳng nghiệp viên phù.
Đại thẳng một sוד 5.5.5.
Với những thành kiểu có tính lịch sự của thông quốc đội mới,
xây dựng và phát triển đất nước,
dựng nên cơ đồ,
kiếm lực, viết thế,
và viết những chiều bao giờ có,
của thông quốc Việt Nam Phôm nay.